no virtue signaling no empty gestures no
armbands just silence and booze from
their supporters in support of that
silence That's What I Call meaningful
protests not capitulating on your
supposed moral stance because somebody
threatens to wave a yellow card at you
I generally think fans are pretty fed up
with all the politics now at this world
cup there's no doubt the FIFA's decision
to take it to Qatar was scandalous as it
was to give it to Russia at the same
time that decision was made 12 years ago
today's massive England win I hope will
Mark a turning point not just for the
England team's stuttering form and also
for the tournament itself this is the
World Cup can we please enjoy the
football
well joining me now is former England
Gokey but he played at three World Cups
Peter Shelton it's also championing the
World Cup's Gambler wears a campaign
alongside him his former Liverpool and
Ireland International Mark Lawrence and
former football manager Harry redknapper
a veritable Trilogy of football legends
before me before I get into this debate
I want to play a clip this is from Roy
Keane today on ITV about the armband Rao
in which he made his normal forthright
views
the players could have done it for the
first game took the punishment whatever
that might be okay and obviously you're
risking saying if he's going to get a
yellow card if that was going to be the
punishment but that would have been a
great statement do it for the first game
if you get your yellow card what a
message that would have been from Kane
or bail take your medicine and then the
next game you move on you don't wear it
because obviously again you'd want to be
getting suspended but I think it was a
big mistake I think
bought players particularly obviously
we're talking about Whalers in England
here
should have stopped at our guns and done
it whatever pressure from outside and
from their own associations
have the belief that's what you believe
then go with it I gotta say I completely
agree with him I mean let's start with
you Mark I mean they got themselves into
a hell of a mess here haven't they the
fa if you're going to Virtue signal for
one of a better phrase if you're gonna
show your virtue for something on a
global stage just do it then just do it
yeah don't say you're gonna do it as a
as a stand and that's why you're not
boycotting it and then bottle it well it
ended up being a come down but the other
thing as well is is and you mentioned
this about the Iranian players look they
they could well go home and end up in
prison or dead or or absolutely totally
100 dead I mean that that is a statement
yes in itself so just a strange one I
mean it's just it's just a small badge I
said it means a lot but a small badge on
your arm one love wear it so you get a
yellow card you know what FIFA like FIFA
would then change the minds wouldn't
they if if everybody
absolutely pathetic in this tournament
well infantino's speech of the day I
mean it's just rambling nonsense and
insulting and all the rest of it unlike
this program and thank you certainly not
tonight uh Peter what are you making
this did you ever do any protests when
you were a World Cup player for England
no not at all I personally I think all
the protests should be done before the
tournament you know I think it's it's
the tournament the World Cup is the
greatest football show that we have and
I think you know it's getting
sidestepped a little bit with with
protests of this and protests of that I
just think look let's do the protesting
before and when we get on the football
pitch let's concentrate on football you
know I don't think players should be
asked to you know
um to to do the things we're asking them
to do you know the problem is I think
some of the players want to do it
they've all got quite moral you know
moral yeah but we're political in the
last few years we don't want to see an
upside to Leading issues to become uh
political right I I just I think
football's football politics and
politics the the problem was that Qatar
was given the World Cup in the first
place because the Fifi should have known
that there was going to be a lot of uh
protesting against certain things have
you said that look look on that point I
mean Mark I I feel quite strongly about
this there's never been a World Cup in
the Middle East which is a fantastic
football loving continent isn't it I
mean we've known so many great countries
there love their football they've never
had a World Cup they're perfectly
entitled to have one they've got issues
with some of their laws and cultures
which we find objectionable fine yeah
but what happens at the next World Cup
which is going to be in America and
Mexico and Canada right you don't think
Mexico has issues we should be concerned
about America has Draconian laws about
abortion for example it has laws about
gun rights which we find objectionable
over here in the UK are we going to have
the same pontificating there the same
protests are we going to have monologues
from presenters no I don't think it'll
be as bad
well I mean the thing is with this is
that for some reason it's like we're
saying that the qataris are just you
know are they lower than us because
they're you know the Arab states Etc
which obviously no but I think the
problem is is end-to-lined in so far as
is we think about the organization
um you know such a small country all
those kind of things the other thing as
well because as we all know that you
know FIFA's corrupt anyway well that's
the problem it has been for years and
years and years and until you sort them
out
it's a waste of time what about the BBC
here being it seems to me morally
selective they're happy to play enough
yeah you know they do it at China but
they don't do it here strange strange
decision now I would imagine and I
wouldn't know but I wouldn't imagine
that would have come from the very very
top right BBC it's a very deliberate
decision if you are if you are living in
the Middle East if you're an Arab
football fan and you're watching the
discrepancy between the way you're being
treated on these things compared to
Russia and China you're not going to be
very happy about it we wouldn't be you'd
be raving math right well yeah I mean we
shouldn't we shouldn't be going down
this road really I mean we should be
talking about England's Great win they
were great weren't they and not Harry
Kane yeah wearing an armband I mean like
I said you know protesting is fine yeah
you know do it before the tournament get
it out the way but once you get on that
pitch you know it's Level Playing Field
and and well let me talk to to Harry
redknapp Harry what do you make of all
this they've got them so into a right
dog's dinner it seems to me
absolutely peers and and like the lads
are saying like Peter just said there
I'm I'm you know I think we're all
getting
it's non-stop you know the World Cup
really is all we hear about it's not the
football it's about do we take the need
do we wear the armband it's just
non-stop let's we look back a few years
you know we got stopped from wearing a
poppy on our shirt you know and England
weren't allowed to win a poppy uh around
you know and we stand for it uh I think
we end up did we wear it on our short or
white shorts or so there was a change of
whatever it's just you know
I don't know we've gone out there to
play This World Cup there's a million
problems going on
everything's you know not right what
they're up to I uh you know uh and
something has to be done about it
obviously if we feel that strong then
Harry Kane would say we're gonna we
should have wore the armbanders I think
there's Roy Keane said take the yellow
card today and get on with it Gareth
Bell take the yellow if you bleed that
strongly well you know what you know
if we're really that morally outraged
don't go right you know we people have
boycotts World Cups if you feel that
strong absolutely but I would say to to
England fans don't get on their high
horse about guitar we did illegally
invade Iraq for example only a few years
ago right we sparked two decades of Isis
terrorism with our illegal invasion of
that country there are lots of people in
the Middle East have a pretty dim view
of what we did uh and we've never been
held accountable they must have a
boycotted England and ask supporting
events because of it and I think if you
are living in the Middle East looking at
that again you think double standards